Clémenceau et Delattre bien sûr
dans le village de nouvelle famille
[Musique]
ce village de Vendée qui les avait
naître tous les deux c'est le village de
l'unité nationale c'est le village qui
rassemble les France et je suis
totalement déterminé à montrer que mon
projet c'est le projet de rupture que la
France attend pour être réparé pour être
réconcilié pour être à nouveau uni et
forte comme le voulait Clemenceau et
Maréchal de Lattre
si on a pas de caractère et c'est
l'adversité qui révèle des grands
caractères Clémenceau perd la victoire
Clémenceau aussi le tigre Valérie
Pécresse la tigresse
[Musique]
c'est quoi le revenu moyen d'une
exploitation laitière en Vendée
[Musique]
encore loin d'être payé au smic horaire
il y a un problème en France c'est que
les revenus d'assistance sont élevés et
les revenus du travail sont faibles et
que quand on travaille comme vous 70
heures par semaine mais on est rémunéré
au SMIC c'est pas acceptable et puis par
ailleurs j'ai oublié de dire que les
produits importés qui respectent pas non
non environnemental on est surtax voilà
c'est pas normal qu'il soit vendu dans
nos dans nos hyper moins cher et si je
suis président de la République je peux
vous dire qu'on aura une discussion avec
Monsieur Johnson et je lui dirai qu'il
ne peut pas sacrifier la qualité à long
terme de la relation
franco-britannique a quelques dizaines
de licence de bateau de pêche donc en
tout cas sachez-le on sera à vos côtés
et puis on y sera avec une équipe de
professionnel
moi je vous propose un projet qui
s'appelle Nouvelle France Nouvelle
France parce que la France est éternelle
une nouvelle parce que le monde de la
brique ne sera pas le même que celui
d'aujourd'hui parce que les Français
inspirés à un nouvel parce que les
Français aspirent à des nouvelles
libertés et je vois qu'il va falloir que
vous leur donner je veux aujourd'hui mes
chers amis vous emmener dans un projet
de nouvelle France
[Applaudissements]